en tant que je fais le taxi way de
réclamation je vais même avait pourri la
vie comme ça shannon
silverbacks et c'est sarens et marton
quoi on va où c'est un cheval 30 oc vous
savez un itinéraire agréé
bonjour
je prends je suis là je vais prendre
suis là
je préfère
je suis allergique aux couleurs grises
c'est je préfère le blanc
qui tient autant du monde de leur vie si
non non non non non quoi vous remontez
la ville
a ouai mais attendez j'ai le droit de
savoir la vie trouver l'écouté dessus
comment ça va
quelque chose il ya un papier comme
quand j'ai pas le droit d'avoir la vitre
ouverte plutôt pas discuté au prince
nous a fourni une autre voiture parce
que je me dis je j'ai là particulier
alors on va papa c'est normal pour ça on
est celle comme ça
va démarrer pas moi je m'en fous de
manière je veux pas vous démarriez moi
j'ai envie de me reposer là alors
seigneur zac si je prends la lutte de
repos ici et je paye ou pas comment je
paye ou pas c'est pas un lieu de haut
pour monsieur vous me parlez si vous
voulez vous pouvez me parler hein c'est
pas un problème
vous diront g permet juste pour
m'endormir
racontez moi une histoire quelque chose
féru du dragon
comment
cela la petite la première à gauche la
seine par est d'accord on y va vous y
allez quand même bah oui
je peux pas vous emmener à 20 est mais
pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas c'est vrai rêver mais
je veux bien mais enfin là ça finit par
faire beau pas loin moi je veux pas et
vous emmener en taxi quand même mais
pourquoi elle est là voyons royal à pied
là je ne sens pas lé nom et pg ou parce
que j'ai pas que ça à faire non plus non
monsieur je vous emmènerai passer par la
presse est en train de faire un refus de
vente monsieur mais monsieur je vous
emmènerai pas ou de dragon oil et
l'abonné comme faso c'est votre licence
je vais prendre votre numéro vous avez
passé en conseil conseil d italie c'est
complètement idiot votre peur oui c'est
idiot ben n'empêche que moi j'ai envie
d'aller rue du dragon dans votre taxi et
voulait pas voilà et que j'ai le droit
complètement ah bon ah ben oui mais
parce que j'ai envie d'avoir envie de
mon mari
ouais c'est pas de ma faute s'il est
tombé sur vous
[Musique]